glenn young became governor of virginia
last fall no one thought he would he
beat a former governor very well funded
why well the main reason was parents in
virginia like parents everywhere don't
actually want teachers indoctrinated
their kids with their weird political
views because it's creepy as hell and
not what school is for
well voters in florida sent the same
message last night in florida
republicans flipped five majority left
school districts in big counties
miami-dade sarasota duvall martin clay
miami-dade alone has more than 300 000
students it's one of the biggest school
districts in the country
have this happen what does it mean ron
desantis runs florida he's the governor
he joins us tonight governor thanks so
much for coming on this seems like a big
story how'd this happen and what does it
mean
well we made a concerted effort on these
races tucker for precise of the reasons
you said parents are seeing what's going
on now more than ever so there was a lot
of energy and that's important to
harness but it's also important to
educate
other republican voters who may be your
grandparents now or maybe they don't
have kids in the house anymore but i
think all really understand that we got
to get this education stuff right so we
worked hard in 30 different races we
ended up winning 25 of the races that i
was involved in as you said some of that
were sweeps to where you have school
boards that were majority left now
majority right part of the problem that
we saw with this is you would have red
counties but because the the school
board races under our constitution are
nonpartisan the union would back a
leftist fund the leftists and you'd have
a left-wing school board representing a
conservative county so we have fixed
that in many of these places to where
the school boards are now going to be
representative of the values of the
people that live there
yeah and people weren't paying attention
i mean did you have trouble convincing
people that this was worth getting
involved in
i think
a little bit but what we did we had no
other races on the republican side there
was no governor primary senate attorney
general this was really it we had a
handful of legislative races but this is
what we told voters were important and i
do think that it that it impacted it i
think our turnout overall would have
been less had there not been
this effort with the school board and i
think more and more are getting the
picture that this is important but i do
think as successful as it was this is
just step one we're going to
institutionalize
this going forward
so that we have good candidates running
in these school board races as a matter
of course and so this is part of how
we're educating voters to make sure that
we have people on those school school
boards who want to educate kids not
indoctrinate kids and that are going to
be reflective of the values of the
communities that they serve
so i want to ask you quickly about your
race we learned the other day on last
tuesday that charlie crist who beat the
zany weed lady he was running against is
going to be your opponent and chris the
former republican came out today with a
message to your supporters which i want
our viewers to see here it is
those who support the governor should
stay with him and vote for him and i
don't want your vote
if you have that hate in your heart keep
it there
i want the vote of the people of florida
who care about our state
he doesn't want your vote you're morally
beneath him i've never seen a politician
say that
this is his fifth decade running for
office he's a chameleon typical career
politician but you know tucker people
support me because i kept the state open
and protected their jobs charlie crist
wanted it locked down so that's not hate
in their heart they're just appreciative
that they had a governor who was
standing up for them parents around the
state support me
because we made sure schools were open
and we're working to make sure they get
education not indoctrination that's not
hate in their heart they're just
appreciative that they have a governor
that's fighting for them
it's kind of weird to see charlie crist
look down his nose at voters is there
anyone in the state who is more morally
suspect than charlie crist who's
registered to vote that you're aware of
i'll tell you what uh i would take uh
yeah i i don't think you can i think he
is not one to be cast in stones and
that's how temptable it is when he says
he claims that he wants to unify florida
he says he wants a florida for all and
then you condemn a majority of the
people in the state of florida give me a
break and the thing about what i've done
is you know we've done issues that
people uh across the spectrum have been
able to agree with and that's really
what it's all about it's not hating the
other side it's trying to have policies
that a majority can agree with
if you don't support me you're a hater
that doesn't work i hope it doesn't
governor thanks so much for coming on
appreciate it